we had a story
several years ago that was published by
gizmodo that facebook was censoring
conservative news because they had this
trending tab and the employees there
were basically told or had this bias
conservative news sources are fake news
so they'd remove them from trending i
remember seeing that i remember seeing
people start getting censored and banned
and and the social media was manipulated
and then i said the republicans are too
stupid to solve this problem to save
their own candidacies their own
representative their own seats
now we have this from the new york post
mark zuckerberg spent
419 million dollars on non-profits ahead
of the 2020 2020 election and got out
the dem vote and they're really not very
grateful for that i don't think they're
they're you know the combination of any
trust and this you know this francis
haugen type regulation
i don't you know there's a conspiracy
theory that she's working with
facebook that she's a fake whistleblower
because she's saying everything
zuckerberg has already said people need
to understand this mark zuckerberg came
out and said please provide us with
regulation so we can deal with this now
all of a sudden a whistleblower comes
out instantly verified on twitter
oh come on and then all uh tomorrow i'll
be in congress and then facebook
releases a statement and guidelines
about how the internet should be
censored right yeah no that i mean they
they do kind of like they would rather
be in a world where they're in control
of regulation i wouldn't be surprised if
there's like some sort of there's some
sort of collusion going on there but
that said the antitrust stuff is no joke
that that stuff is actually going
forward and and it's not helpful to
zuckerberg how are they planning that
what are they doing i mean there's
there's serious uh
like there's already you know they're
looking at a bipartisan law that's
that's more targeted amazon
not allowing you to preference your own
products
um they're still talking hard about
breakup and you know making facebook and
instagram and what's up divest
so what does that do
i mean it's bad for zuckerberg
personally right like you know it does
it do that much i don't know i mean
they're all they're all still leftist
companies i think you know it's sort of
interesting to to see it you know i mean
whenever i talk about like let's make
platform access a civil right i get the
objection from the libertarians like oh
you're using government violated
corporations liberty it's like okay but
that corporation is colluding with the
government to do to violate your liberty
and i don't i don't care for
corporations are people my friend it's
amazing how it's like the democrats
became the party of mitt romney those
are usually koch brother libertarians
and a lot of them don't understand how
big tech is working with the state in
tandem making it not a private company
there's there's no argument i don't
believe that they're private companies
there's no way not even from their start
not not even from their beginning not
even what they're doing now when it
comes to the programs that they're
running and the larger participation
that they have in our political system
they're not they're not innocent
corporations that are a part of the free
capitalistic world they're not yeah it's
it's very like it's very formalist right
they're sort of like if you know
informal government coercion is okay in
the libertarian world it seems like like
you think about think about like the
vaccine mandate debate right
libertarians are like you're violating a
business's liberty if you tell them they
can't uh enforce a vaccine mandate it's
like well like look at a company like
southwest who is clearly talking with
the butt administration regularly by
administration's going like we think
really strongly that you should impose a
vaccine mandate then they do
so basically it's like the formal
exercise of state power by a state
government saying no vaccine mandates is
like the only answer to the informal
exercise of state power by the biden
administration to persuade
these corporations to impose the
mandates in the first place i think this
is why a lot of the libertarian party
doesn't like the mises caucus because
they're getting serious about it but the
the the core of the libertarian party
has always pretty much been we are not
smart enough to recognize the government
is in control of these corporations and
therefore the corporation should be free
to do what they do even though it's
detrimental to everybody
it's like yo libertarians should be
against centralized authority regardless
of where it comes from right a major
corporation can oppress anybody the same
as a government that's a great way to
phrase it centralized authority is the
antithesis of libertarianism absolutely
i don't understand how you can be like
a a a naturally uh
spontaneously formed over 200 years
organization of very powerful
individuals with massive amounts of
wealth and resources controlled an
authoritarian structure is a good thing
that should be left alone
however
the same exact thing with the label on
it says government now that's where the
problem comes in it's like
it's remarkable to me how many of these
libertarians are okay with being coerced
and and forced to walking walking off
the cliff as opposed to i should say
coerced or or manipulated into doing it
versus hard force yeah they're like well
if the government can or if a company
convinces you to hurt yourself that's
fine no no i don't agree that's what i
mean by like overly formalist right it's
like they look at like is this a formal
exercise of government power or not if
it is bad if it's not okay that's fine
like look the bigger picture here in my
opinion is that i mean are we really
going to have a red wave i understand
historically republicans should be in
for a major victory in the house i
understand that based on the data we're
seeing there's good signs a red wave
could happen
but if mark zuckerberg is gonna dump but
have a half a billion dollars to make
sure you don't win what's he gonna do at
his own company to make sure you don't
win when it cost him nothing yeah i mean
he maybe he's not too happy with the end
result i mean you got to account for
that he may not be stoked on the
antitrust thing that's true right like
he might not spend this kind of money
again and also
man i don't know how you fix like i
think trump's sort of a unique
phenomenon where he drives that turnout
on both sides like you know he's
uniquely polarizing people love him
people hate people hate him i think
i think you look at the midterms i i
think i don't know i'm i'm optimistic
about 202 i think we're gonna have a
very good midterm election but is it
gonna be with people who are going to do
something
i mean
i think it's the only thing we can you
know
congress is never going to really do
anything the question is just stopping
democrats right like i think people
people underestimate the value of like
winning the senate for example like it
really is annoying that we didn't win
the senate um it put us in a position
where we're suddenly totally dependent
on christian cinema and joe manchin
doing our you know like
being flaky enough to do that and mitt
romney right and then
like you know i mean
i don't like republicans in the in
congress that much but i know that
they're the people i can influence i
know i have zero meaningful influence
over the democracy i'm i'm i'm sick of
it man i'm i'm not gonna vote for
someone who's like i will hold the
democrats off for two years no screw off
the democrats are coming out and saying
we want to take away all your guns yes
they're saying they won't take away our
guns pay attention all these liberals
claim that's not true don't pay
attention to the laws they tried passing
when they came out and said they want to
ban all semi-automatic weapons which is
basically every single modern gun okay
maybe a little hyperbolic it's almost
every single gun i guess revolvers and
lever action will be okay in bolt action
no they're really trying to do insane
things and the only reason they're not
is because they're going slow about it
i just think republicans aren't going to
do anything i think that you know
ultimately it's still worth stop you
know i basically see it as like a
defense to offense transition i still
hope you know that we can do but the
offense would happen in 2024 retaking
the white house hopefully with like an
executive branch that knows what it's
doing and that's why i'm like i you know
i'm really hoping trump doesn't run i
really really hope like we need
we need this desantis right like yeah
this is the guy but i don't know i i i
agree because you know what ronda
sanchez came out and was like hey it's
columbus day and i was like yeah that's
a little thing right but that's a big
big thing in the long run it's cultural
it matters ronda santa says we're gonna
we're gonna ban you know vaccine
passports
these are big things we can see them
actually doing and so i agree if there
is a republican who says i'm i've done
these things i'm doing them and i will
do more i like that but i'm fairly
convinced in 2022 we're gonna get
republicans we're gonna sit back and say
the best we can do for you is nothing
the best democrats can do for their
constituents is burn the whole place
down now the idea of government to doing
nothing is something that i personally
like i think that should be a motive but
but i know i know we're talking about
two different things here because they
just placate us and they act and pretend
like they're going to be doing something
for us or they're going to be making a
solid stand here but let's not pretend
at the end of the day when the big money
guys come they're going to bow down uh
you know get on their knees and do
unforgiving acts for the multinational
corporations no matter how awful it is
for their constituents so i i you know
desantis is interesting because he is
kind of throwing a wrench into a lot of
the narratives and agenda he's the one
that really did
by himself stand up against the lockdown
stand up against a lot of the mandates a
lot of the restrictions and i think if
it wasn't for him a lot of other people
would have just followed in line and and
complied and obeyed and i think florida
was the first state that said no enough
is enough and and desantis just made a
statement also just a few moments ago
talking about the vaccine mandates where
he said quote the coercion is just
totally wrong i think it's destroying
trust in public health you're going to
end up driving people away and he's
making some good solid logic solid
logical points that i think are
deserving to be considered there's two
things
i i would love to see ron desantis uh
presidential run i i don't know if i
support him completely because i've only
seen the culture war things that he's
done we got to see hard policy stuff too
um
but we're hearing that his wife uh has
cancer oh yeah that's another problem
and so it may be that he doesn't run
yeah that's that's that's true but the
other thing too is what what i've been
told and i remember who told us this
the reason he's so upped up to um you
know up to date on the mod like the of
the current political crisis and culture
war is because of his wife because she
pays attention because she she follows
the news and she follows the cultural
issues and then they sort of work
together and then it keeps him more
informed i'd have to imagine that you
know a governor is actively trying to
maintain fundraising and do all this
political paperwork having a good
partner like that like his wife helping
him stay informed so someone told us
that they said that she's really really
well versed on these issues and that's
his edge yeah they're they're a good
team um but i mean i i give you know
credit like whenever i've seen him talk
about something like he not only did he
do the vaccine many stuff he was one of
the first people to get a big tech law
passed and signed a like anti-big tech
censorship law i think he did texas
recently did one too and the florida
knocked him down they knocked him down
in court but like he got it passed right
right that's that's still impressive and
he understands like the salience and
importance of the issue
and he was and he's ahead of the curve
on that i just trump trump ain't it yeah
like relative i mean and then you know
again we talked about the cockpit right
like ron desantis is going to come in
and he's not going to be dependent on
his lawyers to tell him what his powers
are he's going to be able to read the
you know his needle understand it
himself and like push the limits like
that's why i think obama was so
effective in so many ways is because
obama was a lawyer right and a
constitutional lawyer so
he he understood his office and he
understood exactly what where he could
push when he needed to pull back and as
a result like you know not i don't mean
effective in terms of like moral virtue
but merely effective in terms of
achieving democratic policy i don't i
don't wanna i don't want a president who
will be like a candidate of owning the
libs you know i want to see some
legitimate policies but i imagine he's
going to be for many of the policies i
think would probably be good i imagine
he'd do school choice and things like
that i'd be interested to see his
foreign policy though because i think
that'll be big and one of my concerns is
that we get a rising star who's you know
culture war freedom you know side but
then he turns out to still just be
pro-war establishment in the long run
shoot and you know at this point i just
i really don't want to lose the culture
war anymore it's really it really is
annoying um you know if i can't you know
i feel like we have had a pretty big sea
change in the republican party and
forward policy thanks to trump in a lot
of ways and i'm very grateful to the
former president for that
but you know i really you know i i think
even if desantis isn't perfect on
foreign policy like or sorry
culture
culture war is a game that no one can
win either we stop playing or we're all
going to lose technically you know we we
lose in the way where it's a net
negative across the board but the issue
is lose by how much
well the
the problem is with like the joe rogan
thing sanjay gupta wrote this essay
which is ridiculous and he's saying like
i was warned joe rogan's a bad faith
actor like listen
we we're gonna i want to save the sanjay
gupta stuff but i'll just say this
sanjay gupta says in his essay he's
never had a conversation with someone
that's oh that was three hours or longer
and that to me was like getting smacked
in the face with a baseball bat like
whoa whoa whoa whoa
sanjay gupta never had a conversation
with someone over three hours how old is
this guy is he not married
it was crazy for me to hear this but
these people live in a world where they
don't communicate they just get their
news from the tv
i'm like my whole life i'm sitting
around with my friends in chicago
playing star wars into the republic for
like four or five hours we're just
talking about space time and they were
stoned out of their minds but like these
conversations were crazy and in-depth in
politics and we'd be fact checking
things we're just having fun exploring
ideas he's never done that a
neurosurgeon writer medical reporters
got his head in the books he's been in
the books probably his whole life so
they're he's wrapped up in this
different world thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time